انسحابات واشتباكات في مناطق متفرقه من
المنطقه الشماليه من قطاع غزه وتحديدا
مدينه غزه الانسحابات في المناطق الشماليه
الغربيه للمدينه والاشتباكات في المناطق
الجنوبيه الغربيه للمدينه كما ذكر اسماعيل
الغول قبل قليل كنا نعلم ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في بدايه التوغل البري كانت قد
تغلت بهذا الشكل في المناطق الشماليه من
قطاع غزه على العمق حوالي كيلو متر تقريبا
بهذا الشكل او اكثر قليلا واقل قليلا بهذا
الشكل ولكنها توغلت ايضا بموازاه ذلك بهذا
الشكل عبر الخط الساحلي او ش الرشيد من
الجهه الشماليه الغربيه لمدينه غزه للضغط
اكثر على المناطق الساحليه على الشيخ
رضوان وعلى الشاطئ واتجاها جنوبا نحو
الرمال او الضغط نحو العمق الى جباليا
مخيم جباليا جباليه البلد مدينه غزه بهذا
الشكل هذه الخطوط الزرقاء التي كانت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تسعى من خلالها
للتحرك والضغط على المناطق الشماليه
الغربيه من مدينه غزه لكن خلال الساعات ال
24 الماضيه كانت كان الانسحاب هو الامر
اللافت للنظر انسحبت قوات الاحت
الاسرائيلي من هذه المناطق وصل مواطنون
والصحفيون ونشطاء الى هذه المناطق اذا ما
دخلنا الى هذه المناطق بشكل اقرب فنحن
نتحدث عن مجموعه من المناطق المهمه التي
انسحبت منها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
نتحدث عن منطقه الكرامه
التوام النصر اطراف مخيم الشاطئ ابراج
المخابرات في هذه المنطقه وصولا الى
الصفطاوي والسلاطين ووصولا الى العطاطه كل
هذه المناطق انسحبت منها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ولكنها خلفت دمارا كبيرا
وواسعا كما شاهدنا في مقاطع الفيديو التي
رصدها مراسلونا في هذا المكان اذا هو
انسحاب مهم ولافت للنظر خلال الساعات ال
24 الماضيه لانه اول انسحاب من هذه
المناطق بعد التوغل البري في ال 27 من
اكتوبر تقريبا وصلت الدبابات والاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه الى هذه المناطق في
الاسبوع الاول او الثاني من شهر نوفمبر اي
اننا نتحدث بعد اسبوعين الى ثلاثه اسابيع
من بدء التوغل البري ولكن اللافت النظر في
المنطقه الشماليه هو الاشتباكات في
المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه من مدينه غزه
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
كانت تتمركز عند شارع عشره في المنطقه
الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الغربيه من مدينه غزه
الان بدات بالتقدم بشكل اكثر نحو منطقه تل
الهواء والاشتباكات الان تدور في مناطق
مختلفه من تل الهواء كما ذكر اسماعيل
الغول قبل قليل ان هذه المناطق اصبحت
مناطق حمراء اي ان المواطنين الفلسطينيين
لا يستطيعون التواجد في هذه المناطق هذه
المناطق التي نتحدث عنها هي المناطق
الجنوبيه الغربيه من مدينه غزه كانت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي طبعا قد وصلت الى
مستشفى الشفاء في هذه النقطه وانسحبت
ولكنها تعود الان لتخوض اشتباكات وكما
ذكرت المقاومه الفلسطينيه بانها تخوض
اشتباكات اعود سريعا الى المنطقه الجنوبيه
والاشتباكات والتي ذكرها مراسلنا اسماعين
و والقصف العنيف في المنطقه الغربيه عواجز
سرايا القدس وكتائب القسام للاشتباكات في
محيط مخيم خان يونس مراسلنا اسماعيل ابو
عمر تجول في هذا الشارع المؤدي بين المخيم
وخانيونس المدينه ورصد الدمار الكبير في
هذه المنطقه دمار كبير تعرض له مخيم خان
يونس ولكن الاشتباكات لا تزال متواصله في
منطقه الامل في المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه
من مدينه خان يونس لا تزال الاشتباكات
متواصله ايضا في المنطقه الغربيه من خان
يونس لا تزال متواصله في المنطقه الجنوبيه
الغربيه من مدينه غزه الشمال والجنوب على
حد سواء بالتوازي اشتباكات وانسحابات من
اكثر من منطقه تنفذها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي